[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem donnerstag die vom sport hat
norbert lehmann
wir haben unter anderem diese themen für
sie
sorge in den krankenhäusern die zahl der
korona patienten nimmt zu und nur wenige
ungeimpfte wollen sich jetzt noch impfen
lassen
preise steigen weiter vor allem die
teure energie treibt die inflationsrate
im oktober auf 4,5 prozent und
debakel gegen mönchengladbach nach ihrer
höchsten pokal niederlage überhaupt
zeigen sich die bayern fassungslos
[Musik]
sind wir schon wieder an einem
empfindlichen punkt in der korona
pandemie angekommen obwohl wir jetzt
wirksame impfstoffe haben die
krankenhäuser sagen ja und warnen wieder
vor einer überlastung der kliniken
interessant ist dabei der vergleich mit
den zahlen vom vergangenen herbst
sowohl die neuinfektionen als auch die
sieben tage inzidenz liegen nach angaben
des robert-koch-instituts heute deutlich
höher als genau vor einem jahr
allerdings gab es damals kaum
schnelltests vermutlich wurden viel
weniger infektionen entdeckt heute sind
aber auch mehr intensivbetten mit chor
wird patienten belegt 200 mehr als vor
einem jahr warum das so ist zeigt pablo
celani
mühldorf am inn der ort in bayern ist
deutschlands corona hotspot die inzidenz
liegt dort bei über 600 die intensiv
kapazität des krankenhauses ist bereits
voll ausgeschöpft und mediziner warnen
vor einer bundesweiten überlastung der
kliniken wir sind noch weit entfernt
aber es werden immer mehr kranke die in
die krankenhäuser kommen die
intensivstation laufen wieder voll das
liege auch an der hohen zahl der
ungeimpften 65 prozent von ihnen haben
nach einer umfrage auch in den kommenden
wochen auf keinen fall vor sich impfen
zu lassen wir müssen den im skeptikern
klarmachen dass derjenige der sich nicht
impfen lässt mit seinem leben spielt und
mit dem seiner mitmenschen die zahl der
belegten intensivbetten liegt bei knapp
1800 unter wert könnte noch steigen
unsere sorge ist schon dass wir wiederum
um die 3000 haben werden und das
bedeutet eine einschränkung für die
regelversorgung
innerhalb einer woche stieg die zahl der
koma patientin auf normal stationen um
40 prozent bei den intensivpatienten um
15%
der isolations bereich der
universitätsklinik bonn hier gibt es
fünf sogenannte isolier zellen alle sind
derzeit belegt die patienten sind im
schnitt zehn bis 15 jahre jünger als
noch vor einem jahr
das problem ist dass wir jetzt
ungeimpfte jüngere patienten haben die
krank werden in der natur des jüngeren
menschen liegt es natürlich dass sie
länger durchhalten länger krank sind und
damit unsere intensiv kapazitäten länger
in anspruch nehmen eine dritte impfung
der so genannte booster sei aber vor
allem bei risikopatienten sinnvoll
booster impfung sind wichtig für
risikogruppen das sind
organtransplantierte menschen mit
immunsuppression oder schweren
erkrankungen hier gibt es eine stiko
empfehlung zu die allgemeine bevölkerung
zu ostern sollte man später dann machen
es ist wahrscheinlich sinnvoll das wird
aber die zeit und die auswertung
wissenschaftlicher daten noch zeigen
wichtig sei vor allem da sind sich wohl
alle mediziner einig dass die impfquote
steigen muss
der druck auf ungeimpfte wächst und die
kosten für sie auch wer ohne impfung am
halbwegs normalen leben teilhaben und
ins kino fitnessstudio oder reisen will
der muss den geforderten test selber
zahlen oder draußen bleiben das weckt
offenbar kriminelle energien immer mehr
gefälschte impfpässe tauchen auf sven
regn hat mir in dieser straße im
hamburger osten fand die polizei die
bislang größte fälscherwerkstatt für
impfpässe für 200 euro das stück
verkaufte der mann die dokumente er
hatte den stempel in einem impfzentrum
gestohlen und offensichtlich viele
abnehmer gefunden während der
durchsuchung haben die ermittler 400
impfausweise gefunden 200 davon waren
bereits personalisierte das heißt es
waren bereits personalien in diesen
ausweisen eingetragen in chats wie hier
bei telegramm sind impfpass fälscher zu
finden 2 400 euro ein angebot aus dem
sommer tatsächlich ist der handel mit
blanko impfausweise legal hinweise wie
vertrauliche behandlung der daten aber
lassen schon erahnen an wen sich diese
angebote richten wenn dann fallen die
fälschungen in apotheken auf denn dort
versuchen die betrüger einen digitalen
impfpass einen qr-code zu bekommen wir
sind zu beginn sicher alle selber
überrascht worden dass so was
tatsächlich in dieser häufigkeit
auftritt weil das ja eigentlich auch ein
absolut unsoziales verhalten ist wir
haben ganz viele eindeutige fälschungen
identifiziert und die auch entsprechend
an die polizei weitergeleitet indizien
für eine fälschung können die
chargennummer die nachgemachte arzt
unterschrift oder ein falscher stempel
seien auch das bauchgefühl des
apothekers spielt eine rolle inzwischen
gibt es erste urteile wie jemand
bestraft wird der einen impfausweis
fälscht oder aber mit einem gefälschten
impfausweis ins restaurant oder ins kino
geht wird aktuell von juristen sehr
unterschiedlich beurteilt ist äußerst
umstritten das liegt daran dass es keine
klare gesetzliche rechtsgrundlage gibt
und das ist immer auf die umstände des
einzelfalls ankommt um betrüger bieten
inzwischen auch im qr codes zum kauf an
dieser anbieter twitterte als beleg
einen digitalen ausweis ausgestellt auf
den namen adolf hitler und tatsächlich
bestätigt die prüfe ob der code wird
akzeptiert 350 euro kosten die
gefälschten qr codes im darknet wie
viele fälschungen insgesamt im umlauf
sind kann niemand sagen die bundesländer
haben jedenfalls angekündigt deutlich
härter gegen die betrüger vorzugehen
corona ist auch thema heute bei maybrit
illner um viertel nach ziehen und wie
sich die lage entwickelt können sie
jederzeit nachschauen in unserer zdf
heute app haben wir immer die aktuellen
zahlen auch die lage und die entwicklung
in ihrem landkreis
mehr als 1100 tote an einem tag 40.000
neuinfektionen in russland ist die
korona lage dramatisch deshalb geht das
land wieder in den teil lockdown
angefangen hat heute die hauptstadt
moskau übermorgen ziehen alle anderen
nach behörden schulen und
einkaufszentren müssen schließen
restaurants dürfen nur noch den
straßenverkauf öffnen die sogenannte
arbeitsfreie zeit geht bis september
nach medienberichten haben viele russen
direkt nach der ankündigung urlaub im
ausland gebucht
für viele ist es ausgesprochen
beunruhigend seit monaten steigen die
verbraucherpreise in deutschland in
diesem oktober ist die inflationsrate
bei satten 45 prozent angekommen das ist
nach angaben des statistischen
bundesamts der höchste stand seit 28
jahren am deutlichsten ist das bei den
energiepreisen zu spüren stefan
schlosser
der winter steht langsam vor der tür und
der heizöl vorrat muss aufgefüllt werden
für einen vollen tank muss nihat
kollegen cheech heute deutlich tiefer in
die tasche greifen als vor einem jahr
fast 800 euro mehr
da muss ich ja striche machen was jetzt
vorrang hat und was nicht heizen tanken
strom die energiekosten sind es vor
allem die die inflation auf immer neue
höhen treiben auf aktuell 4,5 prozent im
oktober auch baustoffe und manche
produkte wie halbleiter sowie viele
dienstleistungen sind teurer geworden
experten relativieren aber im letzten
jahr sind die preise gesunken da haben
wir profitiert von fallenden preisen und
jetzt ziehen die preise wieder an vor
allem energiebereich das ist immer noch
einigermaßen überschaubar es tut
natürlich weh wenn wir tanken gehen wenn
wir heizöl bestellen aber im großen und
ganzen ist das noch kein grund sich
sorgen zu machen denn auch im nächsten
jahr wird die inflationsrate wieder
zurückgehen doch verbraucherschützer
sehen die schmerzgrenze für viele schon
erreicht die bundesregierung muss den
menschen helfen die hilfe brauchen das
kann sie über das wohngeld über die
sozialen sicherungssysteme tun die ezb
hat heute nicht auf die entwicklung der
steigenden inflation reagiert sondern
hält weiter an ihrer politik des
billigen geldes fest die zinsen bleiben
bei null
die aktuelle phase höherer inflation
hält zwar länger an als ursprünglich
gedacht dennoch gehen wir davon aus dass
die inflation im lauf des kommenden
jahres sinken wert für nihat kollegin
cic nur ein schwacher trost sie sagt sie
wird jetzt jeden euro zweimal umdrehen
müssen ihr gehalt sei schließlich nicht
gestiegen
fragen wir nach bei valerie haller an
der börse die europäische zentralbank
und auch der wirtschaftsminister betonen
dass die inflationsrate in wenigen
monaten wieder runter geht was macht sie
da so sicher wer die ezb geht davon aus
dass die hohe inflation eine folge der
pandemie es faktoren wie die
zwischenzeitlich niedrigere
mehrwertsteuer hier in deutschland hohe
energiekosten gestörte lieferketten und
materialengpässe all das treibt die
inflation sollte sich aber kommendes
jahr allmählich legen das sagt die ezb
damit ist sie muss man sagen
optimistischer als andere notenbanken in
großbritannien könnten die zinsen schon
nächsten monat steigen um die inflation
in den griff zu bekommen und auch die
amerikanische notenbank hält höhere
zinsen im nächsten jahr zumindest mal
für möglich es gibt nicht nur
notenbanken sondern auch volkswirte die
das deutlich skeptischer sehen als die
ezb ja die gibt es sie meinen dass wir
erst mal mit einer höheren inflation
leben müssen hört zumindest als vor der
pandemie ja und das sind ihre argumente
die klimapolitik gibt es nicht zum
nulltarif da fallen schließlich höhere
steuern und abgaben an was energie
natürlich teurer macht außerdem
verlagern unternehmen teile ihrer
produktion zurück nach deutschland nach
europa und nach deutschland einfach um
lieferengpässe die man gerade erfahren
hat künftig zu vermeiden auch das könnte
produkte teurer machen lange haben die
voll die meisten volkswirte ins gleiche
horn wie die ezb gestoßen aber jetzt
dreht die stimmung und die skeptiker
scheint langsam die oberhand zu bekommen
dankeschön für diese einschätzung
valerie haller aus frankfurt von der
börse
die wirtschaft wächst zwar langsamer als
erhofft aber dennoch beflügelt das
wachstum den arbeitsmarkt im oktober
waren zwei millionen
377.000 menschen ohne arbeit das sind
88.000 weniger als im september
die quote sinkt auf 5,2 prozent im
vergleich zum vorjahr sind sogar
383.000 menschen weniger arbeitslos
weil er jahrelang beruf schreiben mit
dem absender nsu 2.0 verschickt haben
soll wird ein 53 jahre alter berliner
jetzt angeklagt die staatsanwaltschaft
frankfurt am main wird eben beleidigung
bedrohung und volksverhetzung vor es
geht um mehr als 100 briefe und mails
gerichtet an abgeordnete
menschenrechtsaktivisten und eine
frankfurter anwältin der angeklagte
bestreitet die vorwürfe
in die usa dort kämpft präsident biden
um seine hauptanliegen sozial
benachteiligten helfen und das klima
schützen
beides mit sehr viel geld doch selbst
vielen demokraten sind beides pläne zu
teuer sie drohen mit einer blockade im
kongress deshalb hat er sein hilfspaket
jetzt halbiert auf immerhin noch 1,75
billionen us dollar aus washington
benjamin daniel
mit leeren händen deutsche joe biden
keinesfalls auf der weltklimakonferenz
und dem g-20-gipfel aufschlagen seit
monaten versucht der us-präsident seien
sozial und klimapaket durchzusetzen
gegen widerstand der republikaner aber
auch zahlreiche demokraten nun scheint
eine einigung in sicht
viel zu lange wurden die hart
arbeitenden menschen dieser nation die
mittelklasse vom american deal
ausgeschlossen es ist zeit sie wieder
reinzuholen niemand hat alles bekommen
was sie oder er wollte mich
eingeschlossen aber so funktionieren
kompromisse
das paket wurde um die hälfte gestutzt
auf 1,75 billionen dollar mit dem geld
soll der klimaschutz ausgebaut werden
außerdem steuerentlastungen für familien
günstigere kinderbetreuung mehr
gesundheitsleistungen
gestrichen wurden unter anderem pläne
für bezahlte elternzeit und weitere
investitionen in das gesundheitssystem
das sorgt für unmut bei den progressiven
demokraten kritik auch von den
republikanern
millionen dollar werden rausgeschmissen
regierungsbehörden aufgebläht die
inflation ausgeweitet das ist auf dem
tisch und führt zu mehrkosten für uns
alle
ob das paket am ende tatsächlich die
nötigen stimmen bekommt ist nicht sicher
sollte es abgelehnt werden haben einige
demokraten gedroht auch beiden anderes
vorhaben das infrastrukturpaket zu
blockieren sollte es so kommen wäre
beiden mit seinen kernprojekten
gescheitert und damit vielleicht auch
seine präsidentschaft
der brh exit ist zwar längst vollzogen
aber gestritten wird immer noch heftig
um die fischerei jetzt haben die
franzosen einen britischen fischkutter
festgesetzt
großbritannien kontrolliert nach
internationalem recht einen großen teil
der nordsee und damit der fischbestände
dieses gebiet hier boote aus der eu
dürfen dort künftig nur noch mit
genehmigung fischen so regelt es der brh
exit vertrag 210 lizenzen hat frankreich
bisher bekommen zu wenig klagt die
regierung und droht mit konsequenzen
thomas walther
unfreiwillig licht der britische
thriller cornelis gert-jan in le havre
die behörden haben ihn an die kette
gelegt weil er ohne lizenz und
französischen gewässern gefischt habe
das ist kein krieg das ist ein kampf die
franzosen und die fische haben rechte es
wurde ein vertrag unterzeichnet den
müssen wir anwenden der eigentümer teils
schriftlich mit man habe illegal
gefischt das schiff sei wohl in einem
französisch britischen streit
hineingeraten tatsächlich hatte
frankreichs regierung kurz zuvor damit
gedroht politischen fischern das
einlaufenden einige häfen zu untersagen
und lieferungen von großbritannien auf
dem see und auf dem landweg zeitraubend
zu kontrollieren ich verfalle es braucht
die sprache der herzen denn ich fürchte
diese britische regierung versteht
nichts anderes ist die briten
verpflichteten sich auch nach dem eu
austritt franzosen in die gewässer rund
um die kanalinsel jersey zu lassen denn
sie nachweisen dass sie dort schon in
der vergangenheit gefälscht haben doch
eine reihe von anträgen lehnten
britische behörden ab nachdem
französische proteste erfolglos blieben
erhöht paris nun den druck auf london
das ist enttäuschend wir haben unsere
verpflichtungen nach dem abkommen
erfüllt aber die gespräche werden
fortgesetzt sowohl auf ebene mit der eu
kommission als auch mit der
französischen regierung
fischerei ist in frankreich weniger
wirtschaftlich wichtig als emotional vor
allem vor einer präsidentschaftswahl
auch darum hat frankreich nun einen
schuss vor den bug der briten abgefeuert
der vulkan auf la palma kommt nicht zur
ruhe
auch mehr als fünf wochen nach seinem
ausbruch spuckt der kunde welcher feuer
und lava die massen aus geschmolzenen
gestein bedecken rund 9 quadratkilometer
land 2000 gebäude wurden zerstört
große teile der insel sind mit asche
bedeckt auf den dächern der noch
intakten häuser ist nun das militär im
einsatz und hilft dabei die schwarzen
schichten zu entfernen und jetzt zum
dfb-pokal norbert bitterer abend für die
bayern also ich habe mir immer noch die
augen diese 0 zur 5-klatsche einfach
unfassbar auf der einen seite gladbach
die borussia einfach weltklasse obwohl
nur in der liga mittelklasse auf der
anderen seite der meister aus münchen
völlig von der rolle
über diesen historischen abend wird man
sicher noch einige zeit sprechen der fc
bayern im borussia park bereits nach
zwei minuten im rückstand nach dem
fehler von und amerikaner trifft zum 1 0
für gladbach der nächste treffer ganz
besonders bemerkenswert dass zwei zu
null durch bense bei ihm nie das
ergebnis einer traumkombination mit den
bayern als statisten die nach allen
regeln der fußball kunst vorgeführt
werden aber damit nicht genug nach dem
foul von hernandez ein embryo im
münchner strafraum gibt es zu recht
elfmeter den wenn sie bei ihm souverän
zum halbzeitstand von 13 0 verwandelt
die münchner wie im falschen film
clapper sind hier einfach zu hause auch
eine gute mannschaft aber das was wir
heute natürlich erlebt haben weiß ich
nicht ob ich das schon mal erlebt habe
im trikot des fc bayern auch nach dem
seitenwechsel die münchner defensive
erschreckend schwach hier sind das
kupfermetall und hernán dass die sich
nicht einigen können am ball und trifft
zum 4 0 und dann wenig später sogar auch
noch zum 5 0 ein desaster für die bayern
ein fußballfest für die vor
wir wussten gegen fc bayern da braucht
es eine topleistung da braucht man
musste da muss viel passen im spiel und
das hat bei uns heute bei unserem fans
müssen wir uns entschuldigen bei allen
die uns die daumen gedrückt haben das
war natürlich von a bis z gar nix nichts
gepasst vom anfang bis zum ende für die
bayern ist ist die höchste pokal pleite
aller zeiten
[Applaus]
ja und auch in leverkusen eine dicke
überraschung und für die sorgte
zweitligist karlsruhe nach der frühen
ksc führung gelang bayer zwar in der 54
minute durch frempong der längst fällige
ausgleich
ja dann aber nach einem kapitalen fehler
von leverkusens torwart radetzky der
siegtreffer für karlsruhe durch neu in
der 64 minute
sportliche talfahrt massiver druck von
den fans die entlassung von ronald
kuhmann beim fc barcelona ist eigentlich
keine überraschung mehr einen neuen
cheftrainer haben die katalanen noch
nicht gefunden ja und soeben wurden in
manchester die gruppen der frauen
fußball wm 2022 in england ausgelöst
unter trifft deutschland auf starke
gegnerin die rekord europameisterinnen
spielen in der gruppe b gegen dänemark
dem em-zweiten von 2017 sowie gegen
spanien dass es bei der wm 2009 10 bis
ins achtelfinale geschafft hatte und
gegen finnland und los geht's bei dem am
6 juli 2022 angestellte schön nebel oder
sonne das bleibt auch morgen die wetter
kurzfassung mehr hat gleich katharina
bettina schausten begrüßt sie im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn hier
übernimmt morgen jana paris danke für
ihre zeit ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen abend und alles gute auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend aus den resten der unwetter
über sizilien und kräftigen gewitter
wolken hat sich jetzt hier über dem
zentralen mittelmeer tatsächlich ein
medical entwickelt also eine hurrikan
ähnliche struktur über die mittelmeer
über dem mediterranen mehr sie können
hier auf dem letzten bild auch das auge
dieses medikaments erkennen ganz anderes
wetter bei uns da gab es wieder viel
nebel der sich zum teil nur sehr
schleppend auflöste und hier an der
donau zum beispiel oder auch am main und
am mittelrhein gar nicht sonst aber
strahlt heute die sonne und heute nacht
gibt es deswegen auch häufig klaren
sternenhimmel es bildet sich wieder
nebel und die temperaturen sinken
zwischen dem spreewald und dem oberrhein
noch 2 bis 0 grad da kann es also am
boden frostig sein sonst ist es dafür zu
mit morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen
im dauer grauen nur so bei 8 bis 12 grad
sonst werden 14 bis 16 grad erreicht und
im äußersten westen von den
ostfriesischen inseln bis zum oberrhein
sind es 17 bis 19 grad das verdanke
sonnenschein und südwind im norden gibt
es viel sonnenschein im süden einige
nebelfelder von westen kommen die wolken
heran und die bringen uns dann am
wochenende auch etwas regen schönen
abend noch